gg ça avec moi j'aimerais que quelqu'un
racistes à notre atelier si vous êtes
d'accord
un atelier théâtre autour des fables de
la fontaine dans la demeure du roi
soleil
vous allez imaginez que vous vous
promenez dans la forêt de versailles au
temps du roi louis xiv
grande nouveauté est d'habitude réservé
à l'hémicycle du congrès le château de
versailles offre souvenez du midi aux
enfants pour des ateliers art et
éducation
on a multiplié par quatre dans l'espace
on a de nouveaux espaces qui vont faire
250 m² ont vraiment on va pouvoir offrir
quatre fois plus d'ateliers pour les
publics scolaires pour les publics
éloignés pour les familles des espaces
modulables au gré des différentes
activités proposées des plus physiques
comme le théâtre aux activités manuelles
comme la dorure et pour s'inspirer
une visite du château est prévu avant de
passer à la phase activités voile à
regarder ces autocollants d'accord donc
su les tasses et puis tu peux le mettre
pour faire donc là la dentelle le bas de
la robe de la de la duchesse on a une
visite à peu près qui dure une heure et
ils ont une heure d'atelier donc on
convient dans les salles d'ateliers et
là il crée en ayant poussé en
s'inspirant de tous les peintres et
qu'ils ont vu les portraits en pied dont
les portraits d'apparat des rois lui 18
charles disent les enfants
s'enrichissent du château pour
développer leur créativité
là j'ai fait ça après je vais dessiner
la robe
dessiner rock à papier après je vais
prendre ça je décorais pas retenu ce
qu'est ce que j'aime bien déjà à faire
des démarches l'asti on s'amuse et chez
bien l'espace art et éducation est
proposé au groupe scolaire et associatif
sur réservation cinq ou six nouveaux
ateliers devraient voir le jour en 2019
et c'est en ont petit à petit aux
familles